a cop in the Secret Service agent be
sure to give us his top three news
stories of the past seven days great Dan
bungee now joins us tonight hey Dan well
you're lucky because I have four and the
fourth story of the week yes is gonna be
a nice segue from your UFO segment story
number four Tucker
apparently some United States senators
have received an actual briefing on this
UFO phenomenon now like you I always
wonder why this isn't a bigger story
listen Tucker we don't have to go all HG
Welles War of the Worlds already things
no need for drama but if you want some
stuff flying over your country with the
technology no one could explain maybe
it's kind of a bigger deal all right
maybe we should be a little more
concerned just throwing that out there
for the audience you know that's that is
a fair concern I would say thank you
buddy we think alike right all right
the Iranians a very serious story
hitting one of our drones a hundred
million dollar plush drone you know
Tucker you and I don't agree on
everything in politics but I have to
tell you you have my respect on this one
you've been consistent on this from the
start
and I think you've nailed this it's a
drone it's a serious matter
Iran is obviously not a friend to the
United States but as you know I think
you know not some talib describes in his
book you know skin in the game it's very
easy to make these decisions about human
lives when it's not you know your butt
on the line I understand they're serious
decisions but the way some of these
people in DC just casually throw around
war like it's a trip to McDonald's it's
candidly embarrassing for people with
such high IQs or who believe they have
such high IQs so I'm Glenn which is a
better description yeah you did who
believe they do thanks Dan
yeah he was great yeah no good job on
that all right story number two
2020 begins listen we regardless if
you're I'm listen I'm a supporter of the
president I'm a conservative on a lot of
his conservative issues you know I'm not
a news guy I'm an opinion guy I don't
think that's a secret
but listen tucker energy matters and
this rally in Orlando was a monster and
I mean that in a good way not a bad way
I mean you I ran for office you know how
hard it is to turn out twenty thousand
people I live in Florida Tucker I know
you know that it's 94 degrees here on
Christmas it's the greatest state in the
Union I love it but you wake up
Christmas morning and and you could
roast marshmallows on the sidewalk you
had 20,000 people sitting at Hyatt in
Orlando in the pouring rain in 90
degrees waiting to see this guy the
president clearly tapped into something
here that the American public needs and
wants and honestly Tucker the energy
hasn't waned one bit he packed that
entire stadium and listen one quick
thing on this again let crowds are not
necessarily dispositive it doesn't mean
he's gonna wear you know I want to get
hyperbolic on either end but the
Democrats ignoring this phenomenon again
is going to be egg on the face twice if
they underestimate this man's capacity
to win an election
big mistake huge burp whoa Julia Roberts
for pretty woman you like that I would
do that in there pretty funny story
number one the Biden boomerang listen if
you're gonna use identity politics
remember Tucker Joe Biden Mitt Romney
was gonna put you all back in Chains and
the Republicans if you're gonna if this
is gonna be your entire political
strategy attacking people on the basis
of race disingenuously by the way 99% of
the time it's only a matter of time
before boomerangs in your face and it
happened this week with floppy Joe where
of course he made a comment about
working with segregationists and he gave
an opening to people like Booker and
otherwise who don't really believe by
the way that Biden's a racist but saw no
to attack him because that's what they
do so Kraven